samus aran solitary war on the space
pirates terminated their Faison
experiments on Metroid's but the galaxy
is not at peace recognizing a need to
combat the space pirate Menace the
galactic federation launched project
golem a top-secret program to develop
mechanized battle armor based on the
technology in samus aran's power suit
the most elite members of the Galactic
marines were chosen and put through
intense training to form what would
become the Federation force
their first mission is to survey the
three planet Bermuda system and reclaim
an abandoned Federation outpost on the
resource-rich planet excel Sein which
was devastated by a meteor crash twenty
years ago plunging it into an ice age
on Excel seein all that stood in the way
were mere ice hoppers but then the team
came face-to-face with a well known
threat they weren't expecting space
pirates now the only way to survive is
to work as a team to master their ranks
and to take down the space pirates
against all lines
isn't over yet